you're like a train and you're going
from one place to the other that's life
and people come in and out of your train
compartment for a short duration for a
long duration
they're in and out but you are the train
and you have to get from one place to
the other which is the only constant
that we know
so what are we trying to hold on to the
people that are coming in and out and
that includes family
it includes um friends the family you
choose the family that choose you
the ones you're born to it doesn't
matter
this is a solitary journey and the
purpose of it is to be joyous
and that's that's only you hold the key
to that i believe that each and every
one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense today on the
podcast
is the beautiful priyanka chopra jonas
she has a new book out called unfinished
she's a really deep soul she has an
inner knowing her
inner compass is just so well calibrated
that she came into this life with a head
start like she just gets it and she has
wonderful perspective and i think it's
through people like her that we then can
be inspired
to live more um like that person to be
happier to
have a higher opinion of ourselves or
the world itself
and more autonomy in this world which is
what leads to happiness because all we
have is ourselves so
we talk a lot about that and i'm leaving
this conversation
feeling super inspired and i have a
feeling
uh you will too so please enjoy today's
episode with priyanka
in indian culture are things very spicy
yeah indeed food is very spicy
um predominantly spicy it can be made
without
spice as well but the natural nature of
things
is that it would be it's um it's an
explosion of flavor so various different
masalas various different things
always make towards really full flavor
like that's where my love for hot sauce
actually started was when i
started traveling outside of india and
um you know food outside of india was
always so bland for me it was just like
boring
so like just like roast chicken and
vegetables i was like
hot sauce came in handy and that's when
i started loving it
so do you travel with hot sauce i
usually do have hot sauce everywhere it
makes all my
yeah it makes um like our dining table
will always have
a spread of at least four or five and i
collect them from different parts of the
world wherever i travel
the caribbean definitely um
but like i always get a hot sauce from
whichever country i go to
like what would you i mean you've lived
in so many different places
this idea of home is a concept that i
think about a lot just because
i remember you know in the last few
years people had asked me where do you
live and
i was like um like where do i pay taxes
or like where was i born or where do i
own homes like what do you mean
or where do i spend the most time um
do you feel like you have a home
i did feel like you exactly for many
years um
i think for the last about 15
at least uh years i've not lived in a
home
that i owned i've moved around i've
lived in like rentals i've
lived in hotels i've um you know just
been a nomad because i went wherever my
work took me
um and but after i got married you know
i was really craving sort of
just a home and i also wanted to know
where all my [ __ ] was honestly like
my shoes i if with different places
around the world or storage rooms and
i was like oh these shoes the red shoes
are in mumbai or
they're in new york right now and that's
you know it's just really annoying so
um this year during quarantine actually
we moved into
our house um it's like the first house
where i put roots down actually in la
um after years i think
of being completely nomadic so now home
is a concept i understand
but i didn't for a very long time i can
definitely relate to that what do you
um what do you love about being home now
and then like what do you miss about the
nomadic life because i feel like i'm
i have a home but it's funny i've been
traveling a lot these like i've been
gone for a month and so
you know there's an aspect of me because
i'm single for the first time in 16
years
and i'm like i'm also feeling nomadic in
that way that i can just pick up and go
and i don't have the answer to anything
or anyone
other than my sister she likes to keep
me accountable but
but other than that so like there's
there's a there's a duality happening
with me right now but there's a fun
aspect of both so now that you like have
a home
what's the best part about that i think
just
one knowing where all my stuff is and um
realizing that you know there's actually
a real joy
in having a place for everything
everything that you own
has a spot and it's like this is where
my shoes go this is where my toothbrush
goes this is where
you know my napkins go or whatever and
um i didn't see the merit in that when
you live out of a suitcase
at all you know there's such a chaos to
that which is beautiful too
but the the sort of ease
and comfort of not living in clutter
is sort of freeing almost i feel very
liberated um
at having a house you know it's full of
my dogs and friends and family and
um it's it's my space and
there's there's a sense of stability in
that which i didn't know i was craving
and what i did miss because last year i
spent almost
you know six seven months at home which
was a great joy being able to
build your home you know together
yourself
especially because my my both me and my
husband our independent careers are
crazy like we're
always in different parts of the world
so that was
a real blessing but um what i missed at
that time
was um you know uh hotel rooms
and room service and housekeeping
do you like cooking no i hate it
that makes sense but i love the
i love the little chocolates on on your
bed
you know i love having a menu and being
able to order from the menu
and come to your room while you're in
your pajamas so i was suddenly like it
was so funny i was craving that
eating in a robe is so nice and you know
what i also love about room service
is if i order a lot of things i'm not
judged
or if i well or at least they won't tell
you
at least they won't tell you they're
judging i'll just say it's for two
and they'll be like you know they won't
go somebody not somebody else coming and
just
two minutes a good idea yeah i should be
that
like i should be i should do that i
usually feel really guilty when i'm
ordering a bunch of stuff
i never thought that i could actually
say two and they wouldn't know
you said two waters you know a free
water
yeah yeah you know you just you can have
extra silverware for that apple that you
need to cut in the morning i mean
later or in the middle of the night it's
a great idea
yeah yeah there you go trick of the
trade now now that you live in a house
um yeah was there anything emotional
that came up when you
like had that move-in moment when you
kind of did you hit
like a point in time where you thought
um
where you felt almost like the pattern
the pattern of being gone all the time
was uncomfortable
yeah the first time i took a flight out
of la after being at home for about six
seven months
i didn't want to go i was terrified
i was um i was really emotional
um i was filming a movie and i was going
to europe
and i was super emotional you know
having to leave my dogs
my husband my like stuff my home
you know i i sat in almost every room
for the last two days of the house just
because i was feeling really
like i really really felt such a sense
of
gratitude and joy for the you know
six months which could have been so
daunting um
which could have been just you know
terrible
and it was terrible for a lot of people
in the world but
um that space just made me feel safe and
comfortable
and you know covet wasn't gone anywhere
when i was going to work
in october so it was it was like leaving
your safe cocoon how long were you were
you
were you leaving for a long time too
probably oh yeah i left in october
um and now i'm in london and i'm here
for a year
oh my god are you working in london or
are you living in london
yeah i i was working i am working in
london i finished at the production
of another movie and i'm starting a tv
show
now for amazon it's called um the amazon
tv show is called citadel
and it's with the russo brothers and
it's phenomenal it's got richard madden
and some
amazing um cast that's come together in
the movie
and um it's gonna be sick we're filming
it
and you know we were supposed to film it
around the world but technology has
reached such an amazing place that we
can
manage both um but yeah we'll be filming
that to the
end of the year very excited about it
what do you think about london
no i actually really love london it's
really tragic to see it the way it is
it's in full lockdown right now and um
no one's allowed to go anywhere um
essential services are allowed and
filming is allowed
so we can go to set and back yeah i had
i had a flight
going somewhere else that was through
london and it got cancelled like i
booked it
a couple weeks ago and it could have
canceled already um and it's for
next month strictly shut down right now
that's nuts the world is
crazy i mean it's so
just scary you know um i
keep i've been in a very massive bubble
for the last year between you know being
very just being hunkered down at home
when i was in la to even
being on a film set being on a film set
is like worse
because you can't do anything you can't
meet anyone um because you know
if if something happens like to me when
the movie shuts down for a really long
time
yeah so i like actors
yeah actors are fully isolated i've in
fact kidnapped my mother and i've made
her stay here she's been dying to go
back to mumbai
she was here for the holidays and now
i'm just like no don't leave
it's really daunting you know um like
going for me even going on a set
knowing that everyone on the set is
tested
um almost every day or every second day
it's just ev
all of it feels scary like when i go out
for a walk um
you know you walk away when somebody's
walking past like
beside you and it's just it's such a
weird
thing and i i'm very curious i think
that the mental
health um toll that
this year is going to take or kobe is
going to take on people is something
that we're not really prepared for
or we haven't thought about as much i
fear it's becoming the norm
you know like people like it's more
it used to be more shocking to look out
and see people in masks and now if you
don't have one on people look at you and
they're like
you know it's becoming so much more
normal and
i don't know my intuition tells me
that's the point um
i don't know it's this fear state is
just so scary and i i
such compassion for the people
especially like i feel like i've been
very fortunate that i don't have
a lot of people that i have to worry
about as much like i don't have a set i
don't have a team i don't have a group i
don't have
um like um older older
you know parents or grandparents that
i'm seeing all the time but for those
that do man it's a
real it's a real it's an accelerated
issue beyond just going to the grocery
store it totally is i mean i was
especially when we were in la my husband
is type 1 diabetic and that makes him
susceptible
uh you know my mom's older i have asthma
um we were extremely paranoid and
careful
so hence the level of fear being sure
even more when you actually have to go
out into the real world but also craving
it
i miss being able to just do dinner you
know um
just like everyone else's i'm sure but
can you imagine
what makes me feel better is imagine
when the
influenza the spanish flu was happening
they didn't even have
the internet at least we can look at
each other
and you know facetime and zoom that's
true um
can you imagine living at that time when
there was a pandemic
yeah that's true and you know i it's
funny i didn't really think about it
from that perspective but i did look
back at the last pandemic being that one
and look how long it went for and it was
kind of almost a year and a half
and so you know i don't know i've heard
other things that this sort of
scenario this dynamic and the world
could last longer than that
just um from for other reasons but i
mean especially given the fact that you
know
your mood and your attitude spills over
into other
into your work and into other people and
there are things that you do that help
you feel better
or like elevate your mood i mean do you
are there certain things that you take
are there certain practices you have
like meditation
or yoga or working out or is there
anything you do is there a mantra
i do i have gotten really consistent
with working out i never
had that kind of consistency before and
now i crave it i need it i'm aware of my
wellness
um i'm eating cleaner
um i'm taking care of my immune system
making sure i have my vitamins making
sure i have
you know ginger lemon tea um which is
always good to have
i swear this is that's what this is it's
not coffee
but i think just being looking inward
was
very helpful during this instead of you
know
looking for feeling good outwards um
i i spent a lot of time on healing
myself that's
hence writing the book like the book for
me was really
a process of healing like there are
things i've
talked about that i've forgotten that
you know popped up in my memory because
i was writing a memoir
and um because also i was in a
vulnerable place
i guess just like everyone in the world
feeling you know the
weight of the world it really sort of
helped me feel
a sense of pride for what i've achieved
a sense of pride for the life that i've
lived a sense of ease
um and you know
calm and and really gratitude uh
it was the book was a really really
healing experience for me
what were some of those things in the
book that um surprised you
that came through
um just like talking about my childhood
and how how that contributed to the
person that i
am today um especially like the travel
and what my parents stood for um
i also think like looking at my
struggles through my career
you know sort of dissecting my failures
talking about my grief sorrows
rejections sadnesses i just i've never
been
an open person as an actor you know but
90 of my life can be um for public
consumption because i chose a public job
okay but 10 will always be mine and i've
always been very protective
of sort of um my feelings and
my friends and my family of course i
speak to about
you know all those innermost thoughts
but i've never like put it out or spoken
about it even in interviews
to me this is like the in-between
interviews book
everything that i um have not publicly
spoken
is in there i think that surprised me i
didn't expect myself to be
ready to be so open
i feel like i've like excavated my
childhood like
inner child inner child healing
i've you know explored those aspects of
my childhood that
were limiting
in my expansion and my happiness
um i went back to indiana
which i think i've read that you lived
in indianapolis or indiana right
i did i went to high school in
indianapolis so funny
so i went back to indiana for um for the
summer with my
family um and i was you know very
broken and vulnerable from you know
heartbreak and
i went back and i was like wanting them
to
apologize for certain things and admit
certain things and my therapist ended up
telling me nobody holds the keys and i
was like oh
[ __ ] that means i have to do it all
and i think that's the sad thing about
like that sort of expansion is that it's
really up to you
and that no matter what anyone says it's
really up to you whether or not
you can sort of excuse or forgive
or move on or choose to look at someone
or something in a different way
so i'm curious if you're willing to
share just some of those things because
my parents are wonderful and i'm i never
thought like oh my childhood had issues
that were going to come to the surface
but
i think we're similar in a sense that
you know you're a very strong
um opinionated um confident
articulate intelligent woman and
um
you know it's it's this it's admitting
that there are sometimes things that had
happened in the past
that limit us and i'm just curious of
what those things were
because you know strong tries to be
strong all the time but at the end of
the day
the vulnerability is where the progress
is
you're absolutely right in fact i've
dedicated a big chapter in my book
um about this phase that i went through
i was also
um you know nursing my father's death uh
who was very very close to me um my
biggest champion
my biggest cheerleader um and he died
very young at 63
and i went right back to work um i
didn't deal with it i didn't think about
it i also was
nursing a heartache um i also
was i'd moved to america i was in
a new country i didn't have any friends
i just left mumbai and
a thriving career there
and you know starting right at the
beginning with the tv
with the tv show that i did called
quantico and it was a very solitary time
for me
and um i didn't
seek help i should have maybe my that
period for me lasted a good
two years and it was a period of
darkness and
um you know sadness is seductive
it it pulls you closer it's like in the
jungle book
you know it's like trust me come here
and it's so
easy to wallow in self-pity and um
you know think about what could have or
what should have
or you know what what made me behave
this way and blaming myself or looking
for a reason
and your therapist is very right i think
i think two things what i did was i
allowed myself to feel
all the things i cried i
stayed home i didn't meet friends i
incubated
for a long time but all i did was work
like i went to work and there was
nothing else outside of that except
me and my feelings um
i'd cut ties with people and the second
thing which i did which really was
helpful was i i didn't make it about
anyone else
it didn't matter what happened to me why
i behaved a certain way it didn't matter
why the other person behaved a certain
way
it didn't matter it just mattered where
i was going
i sort of let go myself of the burdens
that i
insisted on carrying it was it's my
journey
it has nothing to do with anyone else
you're born alone you're gonna die alone
and i believe that and i opened the book
with this because it was a big
realization for me that you know
you have um you're like a train and
you're going from one place to the other
that's life
and people come in and out of your train
compartment for a short duration for a
long duration
they're in and out but you are the train
and you have to get from one place to
the other which is the only constant
that we know
so what are we trying to hold on to the
people that are coming in and out and
that includes family
it includes um friends the family you
choose the family that choose you
the ones you're born to it doesn't
matter
this is a solitary journey and the
purpose of it is to be joyous
and that's that's only you hold the key
to that
and that doesn't mean you don't feel
shitty and you shouldn't feel bad
but if you allow yourself to feel bad
and you allow yourself to feel something
and not always have to be tough and
strong and
make excuses or find reasons for
behavior whether that's good or bad
according to you
i think it's just a sense of just
letting it all go and focusing on today
and
how beautiful today is going to be and
what you feel like doing today listening
to your body your mind
your heart is very important going easy
on yourself
yeah so true so well said and so
wise to learn that lesson um some people
never learn that lesson
yeah i know and learned that perception
becomes reality some people never grow
and evolve and some people stay
as you so like beautifully said sadness
is seductive
some people stay addicted and swirling
in that sort of
codependency of emotions that
never lets them out and to me
i mean to me that's hell on earth i
think
heaven and hell exist right here they're
in the moment that you can feel
joy and elation and and and awe
and then they're also on the other side
of things where it's
um sadness and lack and jealousy
and you know just anything that doesn't
make you feel good
um are you what is your do you have a
spiritual practice or religious
i mean what is um i'm hindu by religion
and um but i'm my
i'm more spiritual than religious i
believe i've been raised
um religious of course uh and on
holidays like diwali and i'll do the
pujas that i need to do which are prayer
ceremonies and stuff and maybe
every day i'll um we we have in hinduism
we have like a tangible prayer thing
that you can do which is
you know um you light an incense and you
have little stars
um so it's like it's tangible you know
so i do that every
couple of days whenever i can but my
relationship i think with god is of
supreme belief i really do believe that
whatever your face of your faith is
it all leads to the same place you know
faith is it's it's a journey faith is
um it's it it's all taking you
to that feeling you know that larger
higher power
um that connects you know that that
explains the things that you can't
explain there's so much
inexplicable in in life that even
science can explain and i believe that
there is a
higher power i believe that there is
something called destiny and i believe
um in fate but i also believe um
that we're the sum of our choices as our
life goes along
and fate will put you in front of an
opportunity but it's up to us to
recognize it and then to act upon it
um and that i think is our purpose
but my spiritual sense is having you
know a conversation
i started recently actually during
quarantine um my husband and i started
doing this and i now do it with all my
friends and i want to do it with you too
um five things you're grateful for today
today not in life not forever
but just today you mean if you do that
every day
yeah just do it um coffee
rain that's happening randomly in
arizona which it never happens because
it makes everything
beautiful um a platform that gives me an
opportunity to speak to someone like you
a shelf full of books that i'm looking
at that help expand my mind
[Music]
and you know something that i actually
was thinking last night that i thought i
feel so fortunate for and sometimes i
just take it for granted because it's
been so long but just
purely the means to do anything i want
to do i'm so
fortunate there's i just don't have that
burden
and that's uh that's pretty unique isn't
it amazing though
i do that like i randomly just ask
friends or family or text and
it just makes you puts you in such a
place of
gratitude because there's so many things
that
if we start counting we don't have but
if you start counting what you
have you'll see how much more you have
than a lot of people
and that just puts life's balance in
junk for me
um well for me would be um
my movie just came out um really
grateful for that my book just came out
i'm really grateful for that
being able to have a job at a time and
go to work at a time when you know a lot
of people are not being able to go to
work
um health mind my family everyone's been
healthy
safe which is great and
you know again like being able to choose
what i want to do in my life i think i'm
grateful for that every day
to me this puts you in a sort of
an open more open state a state of
receiving like they i think they say
that
gratitude is sort of the ultimate sort
of place to receive
um and i think about like a spiritual
practice i think about
and it makes me kind of think about
signs and synchronicities and when you
start to get open
then you start to see those things a
little bit more easily whether they be
numbers or a certain person that you
thought about pops in
they become synchronicities instead of
coincidences or perhaps nothing i mean i
think when we're like so in our head and
so in negative
thoughts we um are it's hard to be
present enough to notice the things
going on around us so
i'm curious if you've had um
synchronicities
um in your life that have really like
turned your life or have um jumped out
at you
um jobs relationships anything like that
that you can look at now and just say
that was meant for me
my entire career is like
how it started i did not think um
i had no intention of being in the arts
ever
i didn't think i could i didn't think it
was a
job that real people do you know no one
in my family had ever been in
entertainment
and i was like that's like a specific
kind of people that's not me i come
i came from a very academic background
my parents were doctors everyone in my
family
like a good indian family were like
lawyers engineers doctors you know
academic
um and i was good at math and um
physics and i was very fascinated with
tech so i wanted to get into that
um but i'd come back to india after
living in the us as a teenager
and when i moved back my brother who was
10 years old at that time was kicked out
of his room
so that because i was 16 my dad was like
well she gets the room obviously
you're 10 years old you're a boy it's
fine i naturally didn't argue with that
he was really mad at that and i think he
we used to always watch the miss india
pageant at home you know just like
family watch like
miss india miss world whatever and i
don't know what
yeah i don't know what his 10 year old
mind was thinking but he saw
an ad for that in one of the magazines
that my mom reads
and i had just gotten some photos you
know mall shots just for fun
hand on face soft focus them
taken and he brings those to my mom and
he's like
you know i think we should send her this
pageant because then she'll move to
mumbai
and my mom to appease him sent those
pictures
i got selected from this india and you
give me
a competition and i'm gonna like
run and i treated it like a race
but i'd never modeled before i'd never
walked around in
like stilettos forget rings stilettos
sorry and jewelry and hair
um but i learned really quick i won that
pageant i went from this world i won
that pageant at 18
i started getting movie offers i'd never
been on a movie set before
forget knowing that you have to read
lines
stand on a mark have 400 people watching
you and yet be able to perform and all
the things like
i was thrown into a big budget movie
with big actors back in india and
kind of had to learn and i i always felt
like
i had this invisible sort of push in the
direction of the arts
and i just felt so compelled
to take charge of it even though i
didn't have any knowledge of it
and that to me feels like you know a
crazy
thing that the universe has conspired
for me to be where i
am today for so many reasons if that
hadn't happened if my brother at 10
years old didn't want to kick me out of
the room
i probably wouldn't have been here
this is that power like to me this is
the inner knowing this is like
um also maybe something
that you believed is this something that
you truly just believe i think i believe
in excellence and i believe even if i
wasn't in the arts even if i
went into engineering or wherever i went
i would strive for excellence
so it just happened to be that i was in
the arts and i said all right i'm going
to put my head down
i always make a couple of plans i have
plan a plan b plan c
i never put all my eggs in one basket i
have multiple verticals i work in
because i'm not someone maybe like all
right just in case one thing doesn't
work out i have
something else to do um
that's just that's been my nature so i
feel like whatever field i would have
been in
i would have treated it the same way
like as a student
you know constantly learning constantly
evolving
this sounds uh heady
this sounds intellectual um are there
like i have like i'm i've tried very
hard in the last year my
i have a word of the year every year and
last year it was feel and so it was
about
kind of getting out of the head and into
the body and
um does that does that like
make you think of anything do you feel
like your
choices and your actions come from
um a feeling or a little bit of both
i mean you you want to make god laugh
tell her your plans so i don't i don't
plan so far
i plan for the day um i plan for
opportunities and like i don't know
five years five months later even where
i know where i am because my job
requires
my schedule to be set way ahead in
advance but
i don't know what my ambition will be
because i'm always trying a new thing
i'm always like in the flux
and that i think is my body so the idea
of
being excellent is for my head and
recognizing opportunity is in my head
that's so crucial because so many people
are so in their hands that you miss
opportunity when it comes in front of
you
an opportunity is not going to break
your door down it may even be a small
little knock
it's an it's something that maybe you
create for yourself
by recognizing opportunity it could even
be a person that you know that has an
idea or
idea that you have that you've been
sitting on and not working
you know thinking about it there's a gap
in the market and you recognize it
it's recognizing how you can propel
yourself
into your ambition it's recognizing that
you are ambitious if you want to get
somewhere
you've got to make a plan to work
backwards
and then if it works out at least that's
great if it doesn't work out at least
you gave it your best shot
but that's how i treat it but every day
when i walk out of my house or my
bedroom
now we don't walk out of our houses but
when i walk out of my room
every morning and i have my cup of
coffee my plan
is i look at my schedule for the day and
i'm like alright this is what i'm doing
where what do i want to be feeling at
the end of the day
and i kick-start my day no matter what i
am feeling like even if i'm bogged down
or if i'm tired
or upset i kick my work off like if
say for example i was doing hot wings
and i was dying
um but i know that when i'm coming on to
speaking with you
what your podcast requires and what this
show requires and it's my job
to be able to deliver that to the best
of my ability
and i take that attitude which is my
body
um feeling a sense of providing the best
that i can
in everything that i do that's a really
good coverage of the two
because it does take that right because
you can't like eckhart tolle would say
like be present right now i'm like i
can't get anything
done there like you can't if you're not
thinking about that you have to do
things about the past you literally do
you have to do both give it up like you
plan it it's almost like um when i go to
movie set
and i have to memorize my lines i
memorize my lines
three four days before i don't do it um
the day of never or the night before
if it's an important scene you know
because muscle memory is a very
important thing
it like you put it in there and then
you're free to sort of play with those
lines you're free to act because you
already know the technique
and the things that are supposed to come
out of your mouth so in the same way
you make a plan a larger plan okay this
is where i want to get in a year
this is where i want to be in the end of
the year or the end of the week or
whatever your time limit is and figure
out the plan of working backwards if you
want to buy a car how much is the car
going to be for
what how do i break up my payments how
much do i need to earn to make sure i
get this car we all
plan like that that's how we have to
plan our lives and then
let it be and take every step
and try every rung should be an attempt
at
providing excellence in that one thing
and then if it works out
great but it's never going to be bad
because you've you've made a big picture
plan
and you're sort of following what's best
for you
that's that's manifesting yeah that's
manifesting at the highest levels set an
intention
and have a plan because you've now
connected with the future self that has
the car
or has the job or whatever it is that it
but but then that that that element of
detachment
that's the hard one like i feel like i
live in the future so much that
i feel like people tend to be one or the
other and i'm guessing you're probably a
bit of a futurist
um a future caster um and then there are
people that live in the past and they
have a relationship with their memories
and they can't move beyond that and
sometimes
the future vision doesn't allow you to
be
nimble because you're so attached to an
outcome but it's in that detachment
moment where you can just go and it is
what it is
that you release then that grip on
something having to be exact
how can we have that grip i mean we how
can we can't control
anything but ourselves and for any
ambition or any goal that we have it
involves
multiple people unless you're doing
something alone
and if you don't depend on other people
fine you can have stream like control
and grip
you depend on people there's probability
and there's chance
of it not being according to what you
want and that
that's true for relationships that's
true for professional
work that's true for aims and ambitions
that we have to make a plan but you
can't have a death grip on
it because then you're the one who's
going to have
you know pain in your arms and it's your
body that's going to take a toll
not the thing the thing is going to do
what the thing is going to do
do you have a story about some time some
point in time where you did like
hold on too tight or an example of a
story where
you set that intention and it
manifested in a totally unique way that
you could have never seen
i mean maybe maybe miss world yeah miss
world was never
how did that even happen i still can't
sometimes
get over how that happened i can't i'm
looking at you i can see exactly how it
happened and i'm listening to you
so i can hear exactly but um
i think that you know um
[Music]
yeah i guess i as much as i'm talking
about
we shouldn't have a death grip but you
know tight grip
i do sometimes because i expect a level
of
excellence and perfection from the
things that i do so i expect it
from the people around me and
i hold on really tight to this the pace
at which i want the result the pace at
which i want
that excellence and if i were doing it i
could do it a certain way but you know
there are things that you can't control
and i have to check myself a lot of
times saying that
this is you holding on really tight
you can't control it you know i have to
check myself through the day multiple
times too where i'll see myself
like really reacting to you know
or getting frustrated or discouraged by
something not happening the way i would
want to and then you have to sit back
and say all right
that's when the gratitude game really
works
all right i got this done today and i
got that done today
and that happened and this thing was
amazing
you know so it's all right it's like one
thing didn't happen it's not a testament
to
the whole um and you've got to like you
know keep it
checks and balances with who you are and
how you're behaving
it's never about anyone else it's such
an inward
the you know ddf diane von faustenberg
always says
the best relationship you have the most
important relationship you have is the
one with yourself
because no one else can control
how you feel if we build a habit of sort
of looking
inwards instead of you know expecting
joy because of people or validation
because of
work or um you know then
it's always going to be unhealthy you
know you're gonna be a hamster
running but never getting anywhere um
and
it's okay everyone goes through that
phase and i think
we have to tune ourselves to sort of
listening to our bodies listening to our
minds
um checking ourselves having
conversations with ourselves treating
ourselves like we would treat our best
friends
you know giving like how we would give
our friends advice
and being like girl you're behaving like
that girl you're doing this you know
it's the same thing
you're your own best friend we can be
really sweet to ourselves
sure but in those moments sometimes even
when i do it i'm like
it's sometimes uncomfortable it's almost
more comfortable at times
more comfortable to be the critical one
to be the judgmental one because you're
always trying to excel or be better do
better
or maybe it's just a habit i don't know
i think
i i i have those thoughts why is it so
hard for people to be compassionate and
kind
it's like it's literally human nature
forget even ourselves it's in other
people
if you know we can't kindness is
we're so afraid i think as human beings
of
getting hurt of um
a failing of being rejected of being
you know refused those feelings um
are so scary to us that i think we
become like porcupines trying to protect
our heart
in slapping away all the negativity your
energy is so
tied up that you don't even know how to
be nice to yourself
and by being nice to yourself i don't
mean you know a face mask and a pedicure
i mean like actually not berating
yourself for
the choices you feel compelled to make i
mean it's so clear and
speaking to you and seeing you over the
years and
[Music]
diving a little deeper before the
interview to know more about you
that um you know there's such a clear
strength
and confidence and um you know we're all
human like i get it like i'm you know
there's there's aspects always right but
um and so i relate to it in a way
and i'm just so curious what your
experience is um
sometimes it's like sometimes it's
judged
sometimes being a strong woman is um
has its ups and downs have you like what
have you been what are your experiences
with that whether it's in the business
world
or in relationships i think
strong women are and still unfortunately
quite an anomaly because you know we
have to teach our daughters that it's
okay to be tough and it's okay to be
strong
and we have to also be as women
four times stronger or harder or tougher
in jobs where you know there are not too
many women
um especially the kind of jobs we aspire
to be in business and deck
in governance in um you know high powers
of position
um high positions of power and i think
if you have that ambition
it's it's an anomaly it's still not
normal
it's still something that people look at
and it's like oh my gosh she's strong
you know why should that should be like
that should be such a normal thing
so that you know if we we teach our
girls
around the world that they don't have to
conform to
what society sort of expects women to do
you know
um whereas you conform to your
individuality
and not the expected um
i would i would say pressures that you
know the world has put on women
general and that's changing it's
changing with conversation
it's changing with um you know people
like you
people like me having that conversation
about it's okay to be vulnerable
it but it's also okay to demand respect
if you're not getting in it's okay to
demand opportunity if you're not getting
it
it's okay to um create that for yourself
and ask for your rights and pull
yourself out of circumstances that are
defined for you
and um you know i truly have always
believed that
it's the responsibility of each
generation to leave
something in the world that's sort of
better for the next one
our children shouldn't have to inherit
our battles and this is a big battle for
us
females and the position of women in our
society
and being able to
create and have opportunities equal
opportunities
you know equal pay um equal rights on
our lives around the world i think
that's our generation's responsibility
what do you think i have some opinions
about just sort of like what's going on
in the world and
i have i feel as though there's
um a calling for a balance of
masculine and feminine not only within
culture but within ourselves to
cultivate
this balance and i'm curious
what your thoughts are on that i believe
that
i mean what really is masculine and what
really is feminine and who's defined it
i believe in individuality i believe
that you know
everyone should be able to choose how
they love
should be able to choose how they
express should be able to choose
um you know decisions um
in conform to what we've been taught
it should be if you think about what and
i believe
like god created the world so we're not
in tune or in sync with each other our
minds are not telling us to have the
same opinions
so why are our opinions so herded
why is heard mentality like if someone
says something we have to agree to it
and we have to conform
i feel like conformity is
it's so unfortunate um in a beautiful
world like ours which
individuality is so interesting to see
the greatness that each human life can
bring the ideas that
each human mind can create and um that
should not ever be defined by
gender ethnicity and these things which
like are not in your control
like that's just how you're born what is
in your control is how you live your
life and what
how you choose to who you choose to be
and that should be
the freedom we all look for i feel like
this is sort of
in you so i want to ask you like how do
you how do you
cultivate that but i almost think this
is so such a natural
thought for you i think so i i um
i don't think about like i'll do the
most feminine things and i'll do the
most masculine things and
it's just confusing for people around me
and i get jokes all the time like
my closest friends are like you're
basically a man and like
you know other sometimes my friends
would be like never would expect you to
do that and it's so like girly
and you know but i'm not defined by
either or
like i do what i like so then my next
question is how do we
cultivate that right like how would as a
if you were giving advice
based on sort of having a little bit
more of an observer perspective
of how you're able to access these
aspects of yourself that are truly just
individual to you
and just true to yourself then how can
someone start to embody
more of this uniqueness that is them
without trying to put a label it's a
practice it's not something
i mean it's not something i knew in my
20s it took me to be in my 30s and
with maturity i think um i started
realizing that you know
i only have me for the rest of my life
to keep me company
everyone else is sort of you know
transient and um
i think it's very and i you know
meditation and hinduism i know for sure
um teaches that and a lot of religions
sort of and spiritual
spiritual teachers talk about sort of
letting go of the burdens of
you know that we build for ourselves and
it's basically practicing that it's
practicing
and recognizing that you are your own
nucleus
like if you think about molecules you
know there's one nucleus and everyone
else is sort of
moving around you have your own protons
neutrons like sorry science kids i'm
going to give you a science
metaphor but and then you're your own
nucleus and the person walking in front
of you that person is his own nucleus
and you are your own nucleus
and it's not we're going to interact
with each other we'll procreate we'll
you know
do more together but at the same time
i'm in the center of my life and my
choices i think you start practicing
that mindset
then you stop being defined by people's
expectations of you and you don't
require validation
from other people except yourself and
that's such a freeing liberating thought
it's if you practice putting yourself in
that position
every day even for a couple of hours you
start feeling that way you walk out of
your morning when you have your morning
coffee you're like
you know this is my life and everything
else including my children my family my
job
everything is because i am here
it all exists because and give yourself
that importance because your life is
important
each life is a gift and we've got to
you know understand how the gravity of
that
and treat it with that kind of love and
joy because i'm
i would say that i err i have erred on
the side of being codependent so have i
i me too oh you're human
um but you know that being quite simply
as
in in layman's terms because it's such a
like
you know i heard codependency i'm like
i'm not codependent i don't need anybody
but it's
it's the nuance the nuance of it is that
you rely on someone else or something
else to make you happy
basically and i remember starting to
write down every day like
okay let's write down five things that i
want to do for me today and i was like
uh exactly making
breakfast nope that's not it um and i it
really was
hard to like think of five things every
day that i wanted to do for myself but
for me that started to be the practice
of like um more of that autonomy more of
that
nucleus sort of um
[Music]
visualization uh of my day it's totally
hard but you can still you can still
need people you can still love
wholeheartedly
because that's the only way to love is
to give you know you give fully you love
fully
um if you want to make breakfast for
someone every day it's okay to make it
as long as you want to do it
you see the difference did you want to
do it or did you do it because that will
make the other person happy
and hence will give you validation and
make you feel happy
that's the difference right i'm curious
what your thoughts are
um my therapist gets some real she's had
some real gems for me
um as they do um
and she's she said that uh you can love
unconditionally
but relationships are conditional
do you agree with that i mean yeah i
wouldn't want
my guy cheating on me like those kind of
conditions
right exactly so innately there's a
condition right innately there's a
condition
definitely i think by by unconditional
i guess we've used unconditional as a
word rather
um freely but i think unconditional
in that sense really means that you know
i love you for everything you are um
and if that includes but
i guess there is a but of you know but
these are the things that don't work for
me
if you're going to be in a relationship
like that people have their own various
individual relationships right but i
think
um they're definitely conditional and
it's okay
for them to be conditional but loving
when you're
in a relationship i believe again like
you know the train thing people come in
and out of your life
so everyone as soon as my dad died i
realized
i was like oh no one's around forever
the person i thought that would always
be cheering for me when i wanted a
reward
or would always be like oh my gosh he
did this movie
like he used to get embarrassingly
excited about things that
you know um that happened in my life and
suddenly there was silence and that
noise was gone
and and i felt abandoned
alone but it was death and i couldn't be
angry
i couldn't be mad and then i realized
that death is the extreme version of
the transient relationships that we have
in human life
what does forever really mean how do you
know
you have to do the best you can in the
time you have with each other
and when you know that you gave it your
best in that relationship
and you did everything you could to be
right to be happy
then you can very easily walk away with
feeling a sense of lightness you know
you'll reach a point in your heart
where you will feel a sense of lightness
because you have to forgive yourself
it wasn't your fault you know some
things don't work out whether that's a
relationship whether it's a job
it's supposed to be in your life for
just that durian and you learn something
from it
and then it's like a it's like a scar
you know
it's you wear it like a medal instead of
something ugly
you have really wise perspective and um
i'm curious if you feel as though you
have
an awareness to what your purpose is i
don't know
what my larger purpose is i just know
that
it's to be happy every day and
i think you know i'm
grateful to have the gift of life i'm
very grateful to have the gift of my
life
um i work every single day to make sure
i
better it and i feel a sense of
purpose by in what i'm doing um my work
gives me a big sense of purpose
um it's my greatest pride and joy it's
self-made
i built it on my back my blood sweat and
tears
and um you know i take a lot of pride in
it
so that gives me the largest sense of
purpose is as
every time i push the goal post a little
further every time i
break a glass ceiling for myself i'm
just like you know
it makes me feel like waking up the next
day and doing something else
if you were to
imagine and think about how you would be
remembered
like how do you want people to remember
you what do you want to have
accomplished or done that would
leave your stamp on the world well i
mean on the world i would hope
that um i'm remembered for
having contributed to the arts you know
i've been doing it now for 20 years and
as a producer as an entertainer um
an actor and all the like the business
and all the things that i'm doing i
i hope to that i'll be remembered for
having pushed the needle
in the right direction because it's been
my quest
i always try to walk the path that you
know are pushed
um norm not just for myself
but for people who look like me girls
women
because i had to do a lot of that it
shouldn't be so hard
to get to create opportunities it
shouldn't be so hard for us to get where
we want to get
um when it's so much easier for you know
a specific kind of people or
a specific gender um so i hope to be
remembered for having contributed
to pushing the envelope in the arts
when people read your book unfinished
what do you hope they take away from it
for people who know me i hope
they get to know me a little bit better
a little bit more than just
a headline or a fashion meme um
and i hope for people who don't know me
that um they see that you know i'm
i was a young girl from an unassuming
family in a small town in india and
i built a formidable career that i
am proud of that i wanted to achieve
that gives me a sense of stability and
comfort in a career that's not stable
actually you know we don't know where
our next check's coming from
you have to hustle for the next job but
i feel a sense of
competence in my abilities it took me 20
years to get here but i do
so i hope that for people who don't know
me who read the book
see that if i can do it anyone can i
have no doubt that they will
and congratulations writing a book is
such a world it's so hard
there's a lot that goes in so hard i
feel like you're a really cool girl and
i wish we could have done it in person
but we're definitely going to when the
world
you know gets normal you and i are both
here and we're definitely going to be
able to sit together and have a cup of
coffee and chat
because i love talking to you you're
very insightful it's really nice
thank you so are you i mean you have an
uh inner compass and inner wisdom
um that's you know
more of an evolved old soul sort of sort
of soul where you just have an inner
knowing
um you have an evolved consciousness
that you know
is just a little bit more ready for the
world
thank god otherwise i would have buckled
long time ago
[Laughter]
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button